I got a king of the sting it for you
they're smoking weed in the morning
for me it kind of loosens me up
what do you think that's what you do for
a job my man yeah dude why don't you
flying my plane
right now
you ever met this guy oh I'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea
[Music]
damn dude so y'all went to first grade
[Music]
I mean I've been to first grade but uh
yeah it's Tiger's first day of first
grade daddy growing up you want to
freeze those little gremlins really yeah
was it what was it like did y'all like
what did he wear or whatever they have
to wear uniforms no way strict uniform
code but you can get pretty
lit with the kicks you know oh yeah good
shoes give them some dope cakes
first grade dude who took him me
damn first grade you don't miss first
grade do you remember your first grade
huh you were my first grade like first
day of first grade I think I do man I
pissed my pants did you yep that was
last week dude I saw the clip I also
pissed last week but first first day of
uh first grade Virginia Court Elementary
pissed my pants though why I don't know
I was in first grade
you can piss your pants it means you
you're supposed to be getting an
education I know and my mom no one came
and dropped off a second pair of pants I
was just you know when the piss at first
is kind of nice when it's warm then it
gets freezing cold then uncomfortable
yeah from yeah that's true dude and then
at lunchtime my lunch has dried up ah
that denim man it was denim jeans it it
was wet all day kids forget kids forget
that about 1 pm every kid forget that
you pissed they move on to another kid
yeah they make fun of another kid
somebody else pissed you don't remember
first grade I remember certain things of
kindergarten like certain things I
remember they had like a blow up like
alphabet like blow up alphabet you don't
remember that very well no not the
alphabet well the problem was is they
weren't even in order oh that's when it
all started at all day one oh it all
made perfect sense yeah dang
I'm trying to think of what I remember I
remember meeting my buddy Scott and we
became friends like right I walked right
in the school met him ladies man yeah
Ladies Man real ladies man right there
yeah he was I wasn't I was the guy that
always take the notes from him to his
girls oh you're the middle man you're
the delivery guy Macy is an assistant in
first grade I was the little henchman
yeah yeah
and sometimes I would even take the note
and I would check no on it just just
because I was jealous he's like man he
came back way too fast he said no I'm
like sorry man I had to do it to you bro
I'm just a messenger Man Don't Kill the
Messenger yeah she's not into it really
she's into me
oh no dude because I was always like
joking around too much and so it was
like girls didn't want to go with that
guy
the joking around too much guy wasn't
like in first grade
I think as the other grades came up yeah
you know it was like if you're joking
around too much it was like that guy was
always a little strange you know strange
and just maybe just a lot you know and
they don't know how to deal with it yeah
yeah I think that's what it was it was
like I don't want to be you know if that
guy jokes around or nobody laughs and
they feel like you know they don't want
to be associated with that they're
bombing in front of the chicks well
that's the risk of being a jokester is
that there's the risk of that uh you
risk some of the women yeah well price
your paper Who's laughing now yeah
that's true most of them still wouldn't
date me probably
you'd be surprised though man what are
you just hitting that it's why it's just
sailing I don't care what it is
blowing something into your nose hey hey
come on hey I'm trying to be a safe
thing when your nose
come on dog come on Daddy how does it
hit pretty hard yeah it's nice you just
freeze everything up bro I like how
you're investigating that but Greg off
Venice [ __ ] Boulevard just like yeah
give me that
oh isn't that a nice Mist I guess so I
guess so
oh yeah boy isn't that nice not bad
how about Nick Nick looked like uh a low
budget oh wow just gonna spin this video
sorry dude that something's in there man
no you're fine just use your foot Doug
oh man guys how about Nick looks like uh
he's doing a little Castaway thing here
yeah how much are you down Nicky
definitely it's over we just weighed in
I won I lost 28 pounds in five weeks
Nick ain't messing around you look
you look sick honest I I'm a little I'm
a little disappointed I was getting all
these weight cut tips from Adrian Nunez
and I just ran out of time I feel like I
have like six pounds of water weight at
me I could have lost but really yeah
yesterday I walked six miles in a sauna
suit and I was just drenched and but I
only lost like four pounds and like I
still had saliva in my mouth I had time
to go Nick's undercovered Savage huh
yeah cause that's not easy man to commit
to that you got to be a little bit crazy
I haven't ate since Saturday you haven't
had you haven't what eight eight seven
eating eaten oh my gosh dude you're like
that guy uh Brian Burke martyr or
whatever that was the the cat the guy
they captured or whatever
that we traded oh uh
unbreakable guy no I don't know oh oh
them yeah you're like the unbreakable
guy you're the unbreakable guy when
they're naked and they're whipping them
and they think they're gonna die and
they're all naked
and I'm like again yeah yeah
dang dude it's crazy I know it's nuts
Nicky your face is actually smaller even
and uh we had 600 on this and Chin uh he
ended up gaining eight pounds heaviest
I've been in I can't even remember what
happened to him
I won by 37. oh that's the most Chinese
emperor thing to do dude you make
everybody in your village starve and you
sit there and you're eating like yeah
but it's your idea yeah I know what's
going on can I say it on there you're
sick it's TFT yeah you're on trt
yeah yeah 100 wow
yeah 100 that yeah you'll retain water
and if your diet's aren't really clean
sodium yeah 110 of that buddy see this
is cool because it's kind of like where
the people from the like who can't come
up to the Palace get to meet the guy in
the palace yeah they realize the guy in
the past didn't really train
the end of the palace was his idea and
you just suffered he's like good job man
anyway like it's not he didn't think
about that he forgot Jim was like oh
yeah we had a bat you know it's way in
oh I've gained 30 pounds dude Nick
that's crazy bro I'm not even joking
dude your head is oh no I was just
saying his head's larger because his
neck's smaller he looks like the teacher
from South Park
he lost weight in his eyes dude his
whole way
I feel like I've always thought I had a
really small head and I've noticed it
since I got skinny and then there's like
it's like a developmental disease that
uh babies get they premature dude always
told him hey he's right it's day one
you've said he didn't want it ever admit
to it I'm almost positive my my mom
smoked too so oh yeah uh we think
cigarettes only uh I yeah who knows
weed's probably not bad for the baby
cigarettes is probably bad for what's
the crack that would get you that small
head you think oh yeah I think it was
more of an upper yeah but hey this one
microcephalic Folly Microsoft I think
that's much more than expected but that
brain stays the same I think buddy yeah
you need one of those helmets Nick
you've never looked more like Billy Bob
Thornton in your life
I think your head looks a normal normal
size it just seems like it is like you
seem like someone put one of those
Voodoo spells on you whatever no the
movie Beatles just so he sprinkles the
powder on his head and shrinks
I think it's because his neck has gotten
smaller dude he's right there okay it's
a good thing you're gonna be fine 185 is
where I want to get back I was 200 when
I started one I'm 170. oh
nine pound Nick they call him nine pound
Nick 40 pound chin damn dude what is so
positives that you notice about it what
are some things that are interesting I
mean the first two weeks when I was I
was just having one giant salad a day
and it was good it'd be like from the
habit or like a Chipotle keto salad and
like I felt amazing it felt Super Fresh
and stuff the last week's just been I've
been starving myself like eight ounces
of meat and that's it and you said you
haven't eaten since Saturday yeah and
are you eating out of a can or what are
you eating out of no I I got an air
fryer and I just uh uh chicken chicken
breast and salmon wow he is man it's
heartbreaking to see it but now I
learned like I'm gonna eat chicken
breast and salmon a lot now that I can
cook in the air fryer it's easy
it tastes good
with that dick do that's the other thing
we lose all that water weight you're you
you've never seen a smaller dick in your
life than when a Fighter's cutting
weights oh yeah I mean it's good that
thing's full of water yeah nothing
shrinks a whiskey Pete told me that
every 15 pounds is a half inch on your
dick so that's a lot that's a that's a
full inch yeah damn yeah it's a myth
that's insane man that's nuts congrats
yeah unbelievable Nick bro keep it going
be like the be like [ __ ] homeboy
after the machine yeah uh yeah audition
for the Bible
dude go go on Naked and Afraid yeah do
Nick and Afraid you look like you've
been on here already it's just you it's
just you and your apartment there you
are that's you Doug
when I was first in L.A and like
in my car and I try to do open mics I
didn't really commit to it but I was at
some place on Hollywood and got
approached for dating naked uh that that
reality show I've never heard of that I
know I was like I was in LA for like two
weeks I was like oh my God this is easy
I didn't do it because it's only up from
here yeah
that's basically porn he doesn't realize
it yeah yeah I was gonna say I've never
heard of that show what network is it is
it on braziers
yeah I don't know yeah Dating Naked Nick
it's a you and another man
it's 75 Wow Let's see that
it's in Chatsworth it's in Chatsworth no
I'm just kidding but that's where a lot
of porn is oh I didn't know that Dating
Naked huh wow and are and they sent in
that black guy that Andre Dawson baby
they're sending that cleanup hitter bro
they always do that that's after I find
love they sent him in and he takes him
I'm like that's the craziest you're
there you think it's just you and this
chick and then the third day you're
making her like a uh like a soup like an
avocado rind porridge and freaking big
old Tyrone Kirby puck
oh King of the triple the big old frank
top the Big Hurt shows up with that big
old Hammer dog yeah God damn it bro yeah
dude I want to let you know that we have
added shows for Saturday November 5th in
San Diego
uh the first two sold out so we now have
shows Saturday November 5th theovan.com
t-o-u-r
guess what man my friends at hellofresh
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep don't
worry about the grocery store you can
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and it doesn't cost a bank load
that's right that's why they're
America's number one meal kit we got you
guys man they packed listen everyone's
busy kids are back in school so you
don't need to worry about dinner
hellofresh Gotcha Covered man they have
meals all right they have delicious
meals with over 30 recipes and 70 plus
convenience items all delivered right to
your freaking door man hellofresh is
here to make your life a little easier
man weeknights we got you we got you man
they're quick and easy meals including
20 minute meals low prep easy cleanup
options take the stress out of meal time
with time saving no fuss recipes ready
and a snap I'm headed to Appleton
Wisconsin this Thursday Friday Saturday
come on out and when you leave you don't
have to rush and make meals you need
hello fresh
if you're in Appleton Wisconsin bring me
hello fresh how about that all right go
to hellofresh.com king16 use the code
king16 for 16 free meals across seven
boxes and you get three special gifts
all right that is hellofresh.com king16
use the code king16 for 16 free meals
across seven boxes and three free gifts
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
football fans the first Sunday Sunday of
the NFL season is finally here I'm so
excited my Broncos are gonna ball out
and my friends at DraftKings are making
sure not only watching football but
you're making bank bro they're giving
new customers I can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the NFL season
right now new customers bet just five
dollars and get 200 in free bets
instantly and as an added bonus for week
one
everyone can experience the thrill of
DraftKings early win promotion it's
simple bet on any NFL team to win if
your team leads by 10 at any point
during the game even if they lose if
they're up by 10 you paid instantly MMA
fans you got hamzat Nate Diaz you got
Tony Ferguson and the leech you got
freaking
um who am I missing you got Rodriguez
and you got Holland it's a great UFC 278
this freaking Saturday 279 278 either
way it's popping 279 big pay-per-view
you hit the NFL you like money my
friends at DraftKings got you covered
download draftking Sportsbook app right
now use the promo code k-a-t-s to get
200 in free bets instantly when you
place the five dollar bet this Sunday
that's code Kats only at draftking
Sportsbook an official Sportsman partner
in the NFL also been on UFC 278 you got
Nate Diaz homthot 279 I keep getting
that wrong just way too hard to keep up
with minimum age eligibility
restrictions Supply Seashore show notes
for details the next page for directions
for disclaimer again draftking
Sportsbook promo code Kats enjoy the
fights enjoy NFL season one DraftKings
hey so on this show what they go on
dates like just normal dates just naked
or is it like naked or outside I've
never seen it but I think they just like
they start their dates naked and then
they go just pick them up in cars and
[ __ ] with their dicks out
That's crazy dude I think I would try to
do I think that thing where you hide
your dick behind your nuts
yeah do you talk about the tuck or just
that yeah that kind of rap so you're
like you know so you're not just showing
everything at first because some people
will will wear leaves and stuff I think
yeah
hey what's up you probably shouldn't be
on the show if you're leafing it up
now I can't believe chin didn't even
press like the bread button for Nick or
the [ __ ] fresh water button
every time you congratulate yourself you
get a cheat meal you wouldn't do
anything oh freaking cheat meal over
here cheat male chips nine pound neck
and cheat meal chin baby
God damn look at Nick's clothes are all
baggy
and the keys you see them hitting the
keys like this with two things like just
hitting it like this oh you don't have
the power though elbow all right we're
live I had completely switched my
wardrobe I started buying these like
bulkier heavier T-shirts because they
don't show your belly but now I got a
whole Whole Decade it's free t-shirts
now you dress like a gate they're all
Theo t-shirts that you couldn't wear it
because you could see my belly mix bone
in over there hell yeah dog speaking I
bet that ass is introverted speaking of
bone-in here's a beautiful young woman
who I would be happy to take home I I
would lose 30 pounds for her yeah dude
she's never losing those 30 pounds I'll
tell you that dude
dang dog she could hold her breath for a
hundred years I bet it was kills dog
damn why is there milk in your lungs
when to play we got them [ __ ] Bonkers
baby
dang it
[Music]
like I'm talking about like messy foods
like chicken wings or ribs like
obviously food that you where your heads
are gonna get dirty
um I especially like wearing gloves
because I usually have long nails and
it's it's like
so hard to get dirt out of them under
from under them sometimes
um so it's just more convenient to wear
gloves and I don't have to try to get
the dirt out I could just take it off
but a lot of people think that I'm
weird for wanting to eat with gloves uh
I just love how sincere she is but yeah
she's really concerned about depends how
far is she going with these gloves we
doing chicken wings like you're going to
Buffalo Wild Wings you got gloves on
like a psychopath and then if she's that
concerned about messiness it's like you
know Shane a freak in the sack you think
getting wild in there unless she's like
let me get my gloves a mask on before we
do this yeah maybe she likes having
gloves on maybe she what did she say she
had it was sure what happened her she
was in a fire or something she's a Messy
eater and she just doesn't like you my
girl wears gloves when she gets like um
uh Boiling Crab yeah sure crawfish
annoys the [ __ ] out of there oh that's
crazy I want to order it where I'm from
if a woman went to a coffee bowl with
gloves on that [ __ ] would be
they would have to be British or
something if you like you know or some
it's messy but that's why you order them
you get messy I lick my fingers I get
messy though yeah I think you can't be
wearing gloves I think yeah I think if
somebody shows up and you're trying to
you know do sex or jump around or
something you can't be having gloves on
my girl would wear gloves when she's uh
flaming hot Cheetos because she doesn't
like want the red [ __ ] on her fingers
see so I guess maybe but then people's
nails are becoming such an art it used
to just be you got your nails painted
now people are getting you know
hieroglyphics on their nails nfts on
them yeah nft they're getting uh little
pictures of like Halloween cat yep
endorsement deals on logos on their
nails yeah they got uh yeah Spinners
yeah people have spanners on their nails
people have uh the little lights I've
seen the during holidays I've seen the
little lights under them
then they act surprised when one breaks
though they're out to here yeah I'm like
oh my God and it's like 30 bucks a nail
now it's like you know you got some
broad wandering around
270 tattoo artists they're putting so
your family tree on there oh yeah
whatever you want
Marilyn Monroe easy say less now you can
be sitting that chair for about six
hours that's a good point now Tim what
do you see about this I know a lot of
this is in your culture that woman's
obviously
she looks Vietnamese to me but my mom
does the same thing when she eats she
uses like those those clear plastic
gloves not the latex ones with the clear
plastic ones they're kind of like baggy
listen she always eats with that listen
she thinks it's hot I I just no I think
it's like a really practical move I'm a
super Messy eater I like just diving in
I I think that should be commonplace
it's just a pencil oh it's a pencil with
a height talking right now and Nick's
like I'm a very messy eater he's like
we're gonna do anything for robotic
energy
sounds fantastic right now he just keeps
Googling brioche over and over again
it's like what is going on it was so
hard to get out of bed
enough
he's always
dude a dog just picks Nick up and buries
him
this is crazy
he prays for a big gust of wind doesn't
come along blow him into traffic
Nick struggles to open his car doors
he uses his hip to hit that crosswalk
button
I'm gonna need a run and start for this
he's down in a football stance
foreign
chocolate Face vanilla face you do
whatever you want girl she's so
attractive I don't care man you look she
looks cute I have no idea what her full
attitude is like like if you take her
somewhere does she like do an umbrella
all the time does she do you know has
you put her under a tarp if you're just
outside like having a do a picnic yeah
is it like is it like hanging out with
Queen Elizabeth like there's a little
bit of sun I gotta [ __ ] hold the
umbrella as we're walking on the street
yeah you know like all of that so she
gets that crazy then I I just can't
handle all that she's a germaphobe but
if she want to put on some [ __ ]
mittens you know some [ __ ] oatmeal
mittens when she gets in yeah also how
about this baby use a fork you [ __ ]
Kook yeah it was awesome
say there's also that hey but here's the
question would you rather use a [ __ ]
Fork like a lady or if I can use the
fork or knife to like cut pizza that's
always weird oh yeah that's all it's
like what are you doing are you are you
a terrorist are you eating pizza with a
fork and knife are you not American but
then what about when she's trying to use
a fork and she's like holding it like
this dude that shouldn't be ridiculous
so I don't know ma'am do you girls take
care of yourself but she can do her you
feel take care of yourself out there
king and the sting and the wing and the
sing and The Bling and whatever else you
guys got going on what up it's Abraham
from San Diego Abraham got a king in her
sting it for you and wing it or whatever
personalized license plates what do you
guys think dealing with that random
State issue letters and numbers
boring or to go with that personalized
hitter let everybody know what you're
about who you are
I had mine for a while
black and yellow in California you know
what's up what just got a new one had an
upgrade oh oh snap
what do you guys think so you're the one
here
damn that is filthy I tried giving you
beat me to it gang gang buzz buzz that's
that brows nah change it flat flap that
is so dope yep yeah I tried getting a
while ago I cut it did you no [ __ ]
nah all right got it fast too pretty
dope what does faster mean I don't know
I don't know either yeah
uh [ __ ] Mark speaks Spanish you don't
know what festoon means it up and the
answers are in Russian Fausto means
happy and lucky but that's 1-0 at being
lucky but just one zero I'll be lucky
for
that thick white last place is filled
that's fired huh I know I thought for
sure a stripper had it or something he
got that thing dog yeah that [ __ ] is
dope steal it dog
you know what I'm saying you tried other
combinations because he doesn't have a
seat or he doesn't have an i or o
thick buy thick buy okay if you get hit
Get It On by a lot of dudes too yeah
I'll be the one wearing gloves
yeah dog if you can take bite damn bro
how much does a personalized license
plate cost I've always thought of it as
like a rich person
oh yeah when I was growing up first when
I was played with something you couldn't
even fathom dude no yeah you're growing
up for like MC Hammer yeah I think I
think it's like 160 surcharge like it
takes a little longer you'll let the
inmates do it they got that at price
points pretty high take forever man they
do it again yeah hell yeah especially
right now the DMV is a nightmare you
think it'd be easier to get that because
it's like it's also like you know
it's going to be easy for people to
remember and [ __ ] sometimes so hard if
somebody drives off doing a crime it's
like L eight oh I know yeah did you get
the license number no yes yeah
[Music]
fart uh the fee for precise let's play
in California is 50 bucks in addition
wow dog so it's 50 bucks on top man
that's not bad that's crazy big in
y'all's culture I was just gonna say um
one of my friends growing up her
nickname was puppet well you know we all
did import racing cars and stuff so that
was kind of popular but her name's
puppet her nickname puppet but she
couldn't get puppets I guess someone
took it so she got pup to e-t so she had
the two a squared and no one knew what's
on that up to it uh yeah that's bad yeah
yeah that's bad and my brother does it
too my brother has a GTR but he says he
puts GTR like multiple R's I think it's
so lame yeah that's kind of lit though
what are some good personalized plates
you think
there's been some funny ones man look up
funny dude Mark looks like The Little
Mermaid you ever noticed that a little
bit
yeah she is hot red hair though I know
but like as you know more adult
um
dude you could be a little mermaid for
[ __ ] uh Halloween though I mean the
way Disney's going he might be the next
Little Mermaid that's a good point live
action baby bro my kid had Nickelodeon
on our Disney Channel like Disney plus
and he's watching Cinderella and just
some dude yeah called Cinder sneaker or
something like that it's like a
Cinderella sneaker thing it's some dude
is jerking off at a [ __ ] uh DFW Shoes
yeah it was not good and he's like up
where they walk up where they run
they're like Jesus
what is this bro oh sorry oh cars huh
he's in Florida you know they have like
the the orange in the middle and it says
it says ass orgy but the the Orange is
like the O so it's like ass rgy but the
Orange is in the middle that person
wears gloves yeah ass orgy
yeah they won't let you do just anything
like there's certain things you can't do
they're lucky they got away with that
yeah you can't do the n-word you could
do
[Laughter]
you could do nwod though did you spell
out just like n and then word yeah
eat the kids first wow that's hilarious
BRB that's insane
top gum yeah summer damn that one just
says Black Top Gun dude that's somebody
that lost their [ __ ] bottom jaw
probably in the military Brendan this
guy's trying to get pulled over black
man oh yeah that's hilarious yeah that's
awesome dude I would get that one ass
orgy
um
instead of asking he's five five
yeah you could probably get that
Honda
uh what would you get Shannon I'm sure
you thought about it you guys said
something so funny with Bible a wink
wink and uh
wink is for like Asian oh like a white
guy actually Asian yeah but then he said
another word too that was super funny oh
whoops
funny are there Winks I've never met a
white kid who wants to be Asian yeah we
had him yeah
there's like people that I knew in a
gang there's a white guy that was in the
Asian gang yeah they're like a white guy
in the Asian gang yep
dude he had long hair and he was crazy
wow he was crazy and he was just all
about the Asian culture yeah
Big Time wow I've never met one of them
did this kid in uh not another team
movie oh definitely no he's just in the
Kung Fu don't get a twisted man that
kid's winked out
wow wink I've never heard of a wink I
think they just made it up which is
perfect wink and wook
here is that same kid grown up
what's up King and the sting in the wing
and the sing uh is your boy Nick coming
at you from Southern Ontario and I got a
king or sing it uh dating your cousin
let me clarify
um I live in an area with a lot of
Mennonites in the area uh which is
basically Amish people if you don't know
what Mennonites are oh yeah so a lot of
us are related to each other we actually
have a website devoted to figuring out
how closely related you are to someone
so you don't get too close from the
family tree with the relationship yeah
Branch buddies yeah the one I've usually
heard in the area his cousins he's all
right second cousin what you doing first
cousin uh that's against God
um well
but yeah I have never done it but think
about it the topic of heated discussion
down here I've brought it up with
American friends and I think it's all
gross so wanted to get your opinion
especially Theo given that you're from
down south where I assume all kinds of
crazy stuff goes on so yeah if you
understand it dating your cousin you
marry your sister with deals from dude
well you know what I've always said dude
if you rearrange the letters assist or
what does it spell
resist and
um you gotta know that you've always
said that man first cousin and I thought
I came up with that actually I thought
it was pretty good that was my favorite
clip I've ever made I think I rearranged
the letters oh you did oh graphic back
in the day I didn't know how to edit it
at all the good old days
um I think yeah first cousin is risky
but the problem is they here's one of
the biggest issues that we've faced in
in America is that there was never any
charting done early on
so you didn't know you know there
weren't Vehicles you couldn't get 60
miles away for sex you couldn't get 40
miles away from the Block radius man
yeah I mean Carl Lewis back then could
get maybe eight miles away for sex
outside that so you're [ __ ] in a real
puddle you know and at that point
somebody's gonna hit something they
shouldn't hit yeah if your cousin has
those [ __ ] graham crackers out the
front damn boy a cheesecake out the bag
boom dude I'm telling you bro it's hard
like how far you want to walk before you
gotta [ __ ]
first house you're like yeah I'm not I
know that no first time second house
you're like uh yeah I remember them I've
met them yeah third fourth house dude
who's that you knock knock oh man not
not who is it am I dead because at that
point it taken you two three days to get
there yeah so that's the thing it's like
how much food do you have how much water
do you have before you have to pull over
and [ __ ] I feel I feel you but now it's
20 22 right so time to change now but in
their Community it's still they're not
you know it's still more it's
old-fashioned yeah yeah
I mean I think look take depends how bad
she is man that's a good point you know
come on bro what are we talking about
here yeah and I know the chances of this
I think are like what are the odds
better I just looked this up the other
day but what are the odds better of a
kid being ill if you have sex oh no it's
science those kids come out as [ __ ]
warlocks man they have horns well that
kid should get to wear a shirt that said
my parents were related and had sex
only at two two to three percent chance
that a kid has a birth defect I'm a
gamble man
foreign
genetic conditions or health problems
I'll tell you what I'm not trying to
unmask anything here but uh his small
head one of the uh
dude he'll gain his head back in a week
dude the vast majority of children of
first cousins are healthy and do not
have problems due to their parents
relatedness it is important to keep in
mind that even for an unrelated couple
there's approximately two there's a
chance child two to three percent chance
their child is born with a genetic birth
defect
oh wait wait do you have a kid it it
it's scary those first six months and
they can do a blood test now to test if
the kid has any issues now really and
then you got to decide I'll let the Lord
I just I just I just see what the Lord
wants the risk for children of first
cousins is increased over this by about
three percent that's not bad
so that's the risk you're taking of
gloating out
it's not bad now Chan what about in your
culture is that frowned upon or not 100
is frowned upon I don't even know any
Asian incest stories well you never hit
yeah I know that you're organized they
do the math or they just don't or they
just don't talk about it you guys keep
secrets better than anything and they
kill one out of a third kid so it's like
you know what I'm saying yeah if you
have a girl right it's a problem in
China you have a girl you gotta hide
that thing you gotta shave her head
these risk babies you know this Baby's
him we said we got our amazing writing
uh
Debate Club yeah look guy I think he
that guy's Mennonite I say look get in
you know if you want to be that bad
apple
now you wanna be the bad boy
get out there and hunt man here we go
nice
sorry Mike from West Virginia boy
in West Virginia man that's the kind of
place where
you know you might be you know you might
go over to a girl's place and start
hooking up with her and next thing you
know
you know y'all live in this you know
what I'm saying it's your house actually
you at that sibling rivalry sometimes
the Rivalry is [ __ ] you know and there's
nothing wrong with that I mean there's
no there's something wrong with it you
shouldn't be
you know here's what was always said
around me when I was growing up if you
if you rearrange the letters of sister
it spells resist
and that's the truth boy so that's the
rule right there you know if you guys if
both you all have the same parents
then
you know what I'm saying you guys no
candles at dinner
[Music]
no dessert daddy
sister like just a ridiculous sister but
damn my sisters were okay you know you
know my sisters wasn't fine bro dude if
you had a fine sister I'm talking like a
like a bombshell sister bro them boners
as a kid
that's it's disgusting it is man and
it's a real shame it's more
it's more of a curse than me yeah it is
I knew about at four man I don't need
the [ __ ] of my life I'm moving out
dude or even if Mark was your brother
dude
[Laughter]
let's take a little break here kids if
you're just moseying around once you go
buy tickets to my Appleton Wisconsin
show this Thursday Friday Saturday
Appleton Wisconsin the next week I'm in
Ontario after that I'm in Boston you're
welcome tickets at thickboy.com because
listen if you're excited for all my tour
dates you should be excited for NFL
football the season is finally here also
this Saturday of the big old UFC
pay-per-view hamzat Nate Diaz it's going
down Tony first inverse the leech yeah
Kevin Holland Daniel Rodriguez oh my God
what if I told you could watch all that
stuff you watch the NFL on Sunday watch
UFC on Saturday and you can make money
with my friends at draftking Sportsbook
an official Sports button partly the NFL
and they're giving you guys new
customers that can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the NFL right
now new customers bet just five dollars
and get 200 in free bets instantly all
right and as an added bonus everyone can
experience the thrill of DraftKings
early win promotion this all you got to
do been on any NFL team if they get up
by 10 even if they lose the game but at
any point during the game Get Up by 10
you get paid instantly MMA fans like I
told you big UFC pay-per-view Nate Diaz
Hamza it's happened in Las Vegas this
Saturday get your mind right get your
money right baby we have some big dogs
on that card get paid bro download
DraftKings Sportsbook app now use promo
code Kats to get 200 in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet this Sunday or Saturday for the UFC
that's code Kats only at draftking
Sportsbook an official Sports button
partner in the NFL minimum age
eligibility restrictions supplies see
show notes for details see next page for
directional disclaimer download
draftking Sportsbook app and use promo
code Kats you're welcome now let's get
back to the freaking program
oh yeah that's my boy it's my buddy
Valencia already hey uh Theo you
actually didn't see the picture we saw
Mark last week oh yeah but they made us
all girls God damn you were fine I was
good looking too Eric was terrible
looking
oh what's everyone picked you but this
was the bonus round here
oh Mark wins
you dress up as a woman for a sketch
yeah but they went yeah yeah I doubt
that homeboy hey homeboy I doubt that oh
it was for Halloween this ain't funny
bro you're like [ __ ] it's June why are
you sweating that dog it was for the for
a sketch we went to The Abbey for six
hours and film he goes for a sketch and
then uh we have to edit a lot of it out
man yeah
dude speaking of State I ran out of gas
yesterday right yeah I literally was
wearing my out of gas merch t-shirt I
run out of gas on Laurel Canyon and
Mulholland oh terrible place right at
the top dude people Furious huh people
calling me the n-word yeah we're driving
by yeah that was me
white people driving but even black
people drive by calling me the n-word
David Spade brought me a [ __ ] gallon
of gas in a can I'm a good dude man
that's very soon he's on the show uh
well this will be here by then but he's
on our show oh yeah Wednesday night if
you're at the top you could have went
back home at least dog I was [ __ ] the
break in the [ __ ] road was probably
about that far and I couldn't get it
into neutral there couldn't be a worse
Place run out of gas one lane windy as
[ __ ] bro
Furious yeah that pissed me the lady on
Triple is like hey what's happening and
I'm like I am gonna die get here if you
don't understand and uh oh
God so Joe Dirt roll up so dead it's so
sad anyway nice of him to bring it but I
was wearing the [ __ ] out of gas
is this just a [ __ ] to sell more merch
I like this I like how you really sold
this thing man bro ice I had I mean it
was just so sad it just breaks my heart
that it happens all the time it happens
to a lot of people Brendan it doesn't
though
especially in Newark there he is there's
me out of the
cared rolling up with the [ __ ]
running back to his [ __ ] car with the
guys uh it's like his aunt's car so yeah
better be
so uh this guy anyway sorry this guy has
a related gas Debate Club
is this Ricky Martin what's up guys
Ricky from Cincinnati Ohio here
everybody in the studio is doing well
we're like Ricky's understanding for you
fellas
with these gas prices going up you're
paying 100 bucks a week to drive this
baby around
are you strapping up one of them
four-legged lawn mowers taking that
[ __ ] up the street to get your Donuts I
want to know let me know
gang gang those Buzz
praise God baby dirty Ricky living well
and he also added on his email to he
said I know they like to get technical
with it so to clarify I can't understand
it is riding a horse to run your errands
assuming you have a horse at your
disposal for free I'm aware they are
expensive to buy and take care of but I
don't want that factored in bonus points
if Theo can tell me something
traumatized a traumatizing story with a
horse he claimed he was scared of horses
on this podcast with the jockey but
didn't go into detail let's get horses
too
people are too chill around horses big
ass thing and then big dicks and Ashley
dicks in your face all the time dude
horses are just bears that know how to
[ __ ] fight none of this you see a
[ __ ] horse's body yeah their beer's
in shape bro not an ounce of fat bro not
a [ __ ] ounce of fish strong man in
Montana my my girl we're riding horses I
hate horses I get on that [ __ ] horse
my girl pretend she's all into him look
at him jack shredded veins vascular two
percent body fat big giant dicks Acosta
Yeah well yeah yeah people with better
cardio yeah I was me my girl Montana and
Ryan horses my son and her [ __ ] horse
kicked my horse in the neck bro just
boom right in the [ __ ] neck
it's heartbreaking man you know I saw a
couple I've talked about this before but
I saw police officers in the French
Quarter one time in New Orleans and one
horse started [ __ ] the other one and
the cops were still in the back of the
horses part of the ride and it's just
like Jesus Christ dude and these people
are barely getting paid it's like 11 and
a half yeah they're taking those dark
arts on [ __ ] Bourbon Street I'm not
riding a shotgun on some damn horse sex
don't be a [ __ ] blocker let that horse
get his you know what I'm saying it's
been a long night
let that horse bust that nut man and Mr
hands it's well documented man you want
to mess with horses be careful man you
get the full horse you feel me that Mr
hands died because of it well there's a
dude also with that east of a video a
guy washes the guy the horse ejaculate
for so long a guy put soap and washed
his hands in it
crazy what horses can do it's like a
[ __ ] fire hose when they bust man
yeah must be nice there's Steel in the
wild right here yep that's what it is
you were uh at a bachelor bar or
something
the boy got that spare tire oh my God
is that really me dude if you you pass
this you start to realize it's not but
there's this right there I'm saying
they're like okay
and it is the standard issue jean shorts
on too
and there's me in the back
and there's my sister dude that's how
close he gets guys how close you rip
willing to wrist man damn uh you have a
beautiful sister Nick did you ever was
there ever any touchy Touch and Go
moments growing up not at all uh she's
very beautiful lady
not at all sir
Wow
real serious not absolutely not Theo not
at all sir she also looks a ton like me
though so I don't see that do you see
that in here I got my entire life
everybody thought it that's why God does
that he wants us to look the same so you
won't procreate with somebody that looks
like you yeah you know
it's a warning it's like the last
warning here's Rocket Man
oh giggity gang buzz buzz video Brian
glasses are dope and Chris damn you got
a question for you uh
the king of your stinging rock climbing
[Music]
um
we're hearing the Yosemite Valley
California
Barefoot whoa a couple dudes huh it's a
multi-pitch tribe climbing
again King understanding it for whatever
I just said a minute ago
dude first of all really cool to send in
a video like that man takes a lot of
thought but that's insane you gotta
climb up there to gay around a little I
think this guy's rolling something up
yeah that dude's definitely rolling up a
little heater bro yeah they're on a
break yeah
smoking the Lord's lettuce he uh I like
rock climbing I was too big for it but I
enjoy it
but that [ __ ] rock climbing I like
REI on that plastic wall that ain't rock
climbing fellas that stuff's hard to do
Brendan if you're a big dude it's it's
challenging that stuff's hard to do
um there's people that die up there fall
off cam Haynes uh best friend man
they're climbing who knows where and
they were hunting those you know sheep
that just chill on the side of the
mountain they're hunting one of those
and they got too high up and he put his
hand or foot somewhere and just the rock
gave out and I mean that's top of the
mountain they lost his best friend like
that he was with him yep yep
price you pay me anyone climb them
[ __ ] rocks man what do you say when
somebody's falling like that
I know what they both said
oh [ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ] or [ __ ] 100 there's nothing
right away
that was him Nick yeah yeah I think rock
climbing is real I mean it's a real good
thing if you can do it you got to have
long legs and arms you got to be able to
reach man it's a Reacher's game oh yeah
if you get that you know if you're this
little you know if you built like a
little uh T-Rex dachshund or whatever
you [ __ ] man yeah you'll be long and
range you have to be built like the girl
the mom off Incredibles really really
thin and long yeah you want to have that
rich pencil yeah do they do a lot of
rock climbing in your country Tim and
your culture I don't think I even know
one one of my friends Asian friends that
does rock climbing wow I don't think so
very white thing it has to be right you
think black people are doing a very
white boy thing I'm sure there's a few
um yeah it's like
um I don't know if there's any black
climbers huh I guarantee there's a few
but for the most of it's a very white
thing it's kind of like camping
did you ever see that documentary on
like the and he was on Rogan too like
the best rock climber in the world uh
free Solo solo and then his girls just
[ __ ] bringing them down he's living
in a van eating out of a [ __ ] pot was
it this guy yeah
that guy that boy can climb like a
[ __ ] goat man yeah and the other guy
who passed away Mark uh
the French guy
what would he passed away he fell off
yeah because they because they would
climb with no ropes free so that's
insane
and he yeah he just fell he went into
the ice damn have you seen that the
alpiness no just show him die yeah it's
good does he die on that I mean he dies
man I don't want to spoil it but I'm not
actually I'm not going to tell you
I'm only gonna watch if he dies at the
end oh Brendan but yeah two men up there
it's just like a really tall tree stand
for deer hunting
oh
yeah it's sad anyway we got sad on here
you know what's weird is when they sleep
like they when they climb all the way to
the [ __ ] the mountain and they sleep
they're just hammocks yeah in the
hammock and they're swinging in the wind
God another Theo in the wild
around a magic the Gathering guard oh
damn wow
get that that's your neck tattoo bro if
anybody has one of those
please kind of send that in
oh and I want to say thank you to uh you
little Jorge bro I'm a keto George a
little keto George gave me these
beautiful this basketball card here of
um Pistol Pete Maravich Louisiana Legend
they just put a statue of him up outside
of and they should the um
the Assembly Center
in uh LSU where the LSU basketball team
plays old pistol it's called the pistol
the Pete Maravich Assembly Center and
there was no statue of him how do I have
a shack statue I got a shack too oh I
bet Shaq went up before pistol there's
pistol right there
behind the mask and those shorts
actually a little too long for him oh I
wasn't seeing what was going on in the
picture I got it
pretty cool and then it's Morton
Anderson right there
who kicked for the Saints for a long
time and he had half of a foot or
something at some point he went to LSU
too no he just gave me this oh but
Pistol Pete won't tell us you he died
out here in Pasadena though but he had a
house in our neighborhood growing Our
Town growing up
was he balling Jason and Josh you had
two kids the kids were really good at
Hoops pistol was gone by then he was
deceased yeah I think he died in 87.
oh yeah
oh yeah he was hitting three pointers
before they had three pointers oh yeah
it reminds me of that autistic kid uh
Jason mcluhan or something he hit six
threes and he's like I was hot as a
pistol and he was all over ESPN it was
like before viral moments yeah then they
cut him yeah they cut him yeah
all right I got a king of the Stinger
for you
they're smoking weed in the morning
for me it kind of loosens me up
right now
well it loosens you up to do nothing
yeah loosen you have to just waste your
life
to me it loosens me up have a cup of
coffee and take a dump yeah probably hit
the ground run Doug yeah I'm I listen
I'm not a weed guy it doesn't mix well
with my body I'll do nothing and eat the
entire [ __ ] house really oh don't
turn into a [ __ ] Cookie Monster yeah
whatever it is we got to get some weed
in the neck then our neck didn't help I
fought it off I smoked the whole time
you did oh yeah
that's how you know you're a pothead
when you go past the [ __ ] journey of
the money wow
wow yeah you're like Zelda well you are
through the waterfall dude that's crazy
disciplined dude with this why'd you
take it so serious relax man just went
on 30 pounds I just I I just had my mind
that it'd be a really funny visual if I
lost like 40 and he gained 10. it didn't
play as well as I thought my mind and no
one's gonna see it but uh I don't know
it it was funny shirts off too before
and after I I had my shirt off when I
weighed in both times not me I wonder if
I could find it but yeah if you have any
pictures of that let's see that I'd love
to see that rip my dress I'll play
anybody who says it helps to smoke weed
in the morning is lying to the Crypt
um what yeah that guy I think it helps
if you're you know
listen if you want to smile on your
front porch for an hour
if you're like friendly as [ __ ] like
this guy for the entire day I
some people can do it you know Rogan
smokes a lot outside him I don't know
anybody blacks
black people are good at smoking weed
they can handle it better yeah I think
black people can handle the studio too
yeah oh they can work all day long in
the studio smoking
yeah black black people are just better
at doing Weed Man It just fits better
with some of their Alchemy or whatever I
think and what and for white people was
it Coke milk
it used to be milk anyway We Were
Somehow somebody [ __ ] that up yeah
move on to Coke because I heard you do a
little coach come with all sorts of
business ideas
[Laughter]
cocaine make you give your damn cocaine
make you give your email address to a
dolphin
you should start doing cocaine man
not a lot but I could see you doing a
little bit we stay on the show if I do
quicker than anything
you never know I'm happy it might help I
might be a great time
try and get you to invest in some Ponzi
scheme of flying cars and [ __ ] write the
plot from Superman seven I don't know if
I could handle being I mean I don't know
if if you do Coke the first thing you
want to do it's just like you just
I don't know I just want to keep doing
more coke until it's gone then I get mad
at somebody
because you ran out yeah it's like [ __ ]
well let's just have a ton of it they're
like who did all the Coke and they're
like you did and you're like you're mad
at yourself yeah
and the worst part is you want to keep
doing it but your body can't handle it
that's the juxtaposition your brain's
like keep doing more and your body's
like we can't do anymore and my friend's
like yes you can your body's like oh you
good and then your dick doesn't work
right oh you feel great yeah you want to
[ __ ] that that's God's Joke Man yeah
gotcha [ __ ] yeah you feel good right
but that dick don't work knock knock
who's there not this dick not this dick
but keep having a good time yeah you
just saw it to worst man oh
I'm glad
oh [ __ ] you would think with science and
technology they'd come up with some [ __ ]
where cocaine's not so bad for you yes
science is trying to do other [ __ ] dude
you know if science comes out where
cocaine isn't so bad for you the half
the world would die off it would be kind
of dope though right well they did that
but that movie dope sick and it killed
like a million people on an opiates yeah
I don't know but like these opiates
aren't that bad we put a candy coating
on them and a million people died yeah
those get me they can't get me every
time you ever took opiate
oh yeah
yeah
that'd be stupid I never took one I
wouldn't mind having one but people get
so hooked on them man
Aaron uh Aaron Rodgers on Rogan said he
was playing games on poker Set uh for a
while just because the pain management
in the NFL was so out of control so long
history of Packers quarterbacks on
narcotics yeah I mean when I fought in
the UFC when I broke my nose after that
they gave like the doctor was my buddy
so he's like here's a whatever a
thousand Percocet and uh oxycodone I was
like say last son got addicted to him it
was a good time though yeah it is what
it is man yeah I got invited on that
Ayahuasca trip that they went on and I
couldn't go
but Brian did an Ayahuasca trip he did
you have I don't want to ruin the story
have Brian tell you the story you
especially you you will laugh your ass
off really bro he couldn't tell the
story on air but he told me off here but
I was laughing so far why couldn't he
Tell It On Air
ah is it risque
damn yeah yeah because I guess I don't
know how shrooms works like you're
supposed to do like three grams he did a
Heroes dose six grams a boy met Satan
himself did he yep
and Satan was black
no
and he said he couldn't stop farting
really yeah this was out of control just
farting
I remember we thought we were Asian one
time we're all high on mushrooms We're
Young and we never seen an Asian really
and we thought we were them these are
these are bad holy [ __ ] wow are you uh
wow that guy trying to fight young gravy
who's trying to fight young gravy
Charlie demello's dad he oh he's blowing
up young gravy yeah young gravy's
killing it he's young gravy he's a real
funner man he's a [ __ ] musician he's
a rapper uh we talked about him on King
this thing a long time ago Theo brought
him up and then we had him on King uh we
had him on this past weekend
um and now he's blown up yeah he's
he's almost like a joke rapper but now
he's popping off and everybody's hearing
his music they're like this guy sucks
but it's like I don't know he's but Nick
looks like you're about to fight Donna
5000 right there
yeah let me see what was the second
picnic when was that that was when we
that was when we uh this is today
and the other one was when you could
lose a little more
yeah I think I actually think I could do
but uh
did the liver hide's half a pound man
the map's starting to pop though daddy
don't stop now I I need to get in the
gym dude I saw somebody doing a doing a
number two in the bathroom in sandals
dude some psychopath
it was like what are we doing what is
how bad has it gotten the public
bathroom and sandals yeah it's like
that's one vote for Biden right there
dude somebody somebody taking a dump and
sandals dude how about a number two and
some Crocs oh god dog
just crazy what happened these days all
right
I've never taken a number two barefoot
no no no no no no no no or at home even
no never
put a three-piece suit on
what up a wing what up Theo when you saw
recently Nelly oh can you get her
stinging eating on the clock sleeping on
your break
hell yeah
and he clearly works at Home Depot we
don't know that Brandon no that's Home
Depot dog we don't think it could be
building
oh we can't say where he works he can
get in trouble no it could be Builder
Square too what's the last thing he said
don't ride him out it could be a place a
scumbag move I don't think so they're
already robbing you blind paying for
seven dollars to move all that Lumber
all the [ __ ] time look I think if
you're not Steve if you're not uh
borrowing stuff from your work then
you're not even part of the company yeah
if you're not cheating the man you ain't
[ __ ] yeah dog I think because like if
you're not having some Frijoles
why you're supposed to be doing
Freemasonry work
here's my problem if it is Home Depot
they're a little uh like dining area is
lit the hot dog the pizza churros they
have a hot dog they have a food area
dudes fantastic dude I think that's the
kitchen area you're not supposed to cook
in there those are for those are for
like like contractors
yeah Home Depot always has like a lit
hot dog truck out front McDonald's too
Costco too
Shake McDonald's what do you mean my
Home Depot's had McDonald's in them wow
Brennan's in there cooking in the spec
kitchens in there for like what oh but
it's operating making a big thing of
pizza rolls in there like what the
ghosts like these are taking forever
taking a [ __ ] in a fake toilet
I'll be right back
uh look bro I think I like if this is
Home Depot and I'm trying to wrap this
guy out but if this is Home Depot I
think that I love going in there I love
like oh what is this you know I like the
smell wood I was just gonna say even I'm
like yeah I'll get some new Roofing you
know yeah just buy random [ __ ] the
Christmas trees just high-fiving Mexican
dudes everywhere yeah you know seeing
like uh Father and Son walked on the
aisle and buy a thing of nails or
whatever I'll just buy a weird screw and
some bolts just for the [ __ ] of it yeah
it's like a toy store for dads yeah like
plants the plants are lit as [ __ ] dude
oh the plant section is awesome how
about a palm tree still have it and
there's always that person out there
that's dressed like uh
Stever when that woman out there yeah
she's the plant expert yeah but she's
annoyed if you ask her about soil yeah
she's like we're growing opium
I'm like chill lady yeah I love the
smell of it yeah have you guys ever used
the work to help out there what'd you
say the help the Mexican guy's outside
have you guys ever used uh no but
they'll build you a [ __ ] 75 condom
yeah seven dollars they're great they're
amazing that's all I'll say sometimes
yeah we did this pretty sick game show
back in the day we were trying to sell
this game show where we'd do prizes for
migrant workers and we picked up about
seven cool guys
from the Home Depot and we did a potato
sack race around like the busiest
intersection in Santa Monica okay and uh
this is Rich white people making these
poor it was crazy it's still out there
somewhere I think it's on YouTube yeah
it was potato sack I think you took that
down oh we did I think it's unlisted uh
dang put it back off okay I went locked
down mode at one point and we unlisted
it yeah be careful though because
because I picked up some of those
workers and then I got robbed
yeah because they're like those places
sweet and like oh he leaves this door
unlocked this door unlocked they came
back on us out of town yeah yeah that's
the problem man it's like
everybody's stealing [ __ ] from everybody
it's not good what did you use them for
chin bed Furniture you did yeah I didn't
want to use them by the way I was with
my girl at the time she wanted to
because she's like she convinced me
she's like if you don't use them you're
gonna go to a different service where
they're okay but these guys actually
really need the money so I was like good
point fine I'll just try it yeah they
were great there's a cheat code for
these [ __ ] out there when Ikea comes
to drop off your furniture you got a
recliner it's in 7 000 pieces she's like
y'all give me a hundred bucks to put
this thing together bro they put
together fast they do because if you pay
for it online it's like 200 bucks to put
the [ __ ] together 100 cash man put that
[ __ ] couch together and that's four
thousand piece Lego they suck and what
about
um uh uh oh yeah putting something
together sucks it sucks when they go I'm
good
yeah well my kids I'll order my kid uh
for like for the birthday you know they
like the cards they can drive the
electric cars you order it from Amazon
like sick online that comes in a [ __ ]
shoe box and then you gotta put it all
together really hours bro and do you do
it with the kid or you have to do it
separate and then give it to your child
no we'll be there but I'll help that and
then after two minutes he dips out now
they're all [ __ ] day sweating my ass
up
I don't put something correctly together
you know it's at night because then he's
like oh Dad didn't even finish his work
or whatever he's like why when I turn
left let's go right I'm like shut up and
enjoy it yeah what did uh when you
dropped him off at school was he scared
or anything no because it's the same kid
he was in summer camp with them and then
he was also in kindergarten with him so
it's all the same kid dude wandering
into school when you're little was so
insane you know
you just walk in there but there's a
there's a part of you that wants them to
be like no dad and turn back like my
two-year-old Boss season Pre-K and I was
like oh he's gonna freak the [ __ ] out
and I dropped him off he's like see ya
all right bye he was like embarrassed
I'm like what the [ __ ]
a little bison yeah man come on dog be
cool man oh here's somebody huh there's
some [ __ ] money because directly
behind them is a 64 Daytona Ferrari
which is [ __ ] ridiculous is it really
that black one's of Daytona too those
are million dollar cars somebody's
balling I'm trying to get 84 Ford Escort
what up Brendan what's up Theo this is
Taylor and Tony brother and sister from
Denver Colorado
they have a F40
.
see that black one
[Music]
already
oh my God where's this at in Colorado
force with the engine in the back
dog
oh damn oh you see the career with the
[ __ ] Mater baby they got a slant nose
somebody is Rich Daddy
[Music]
yeah I'll marry one of them yeah Theo if
you're feeling left
out maybe just
chime in with what your favorite mode of
transportation is I don't know Greyhound
Taxi
hitchhiking
what is it can you sing it yeah for our
or no Debate Club Ferraris or Porsche oh
my God
I don't have to pick I'm trying to flex
on you guys I'm gonna have to pick I
already picked well two of my favorite
cars yeah yeah that's all I have the
favorite cars are Porsche or Ferrari you
guys answer that one in I mean I love
the Dodge Neon I remember like the Dodge
Viper though daddy
um I could see you in that mom got a
Dodge Neon dude and uh my brother and I
would take turns sleeping out in it at
night sleeping in the back seat and that
[ __ ] was nice as hell I uh it was gray
it was like Outdoor gray or whatever so
you know you're getting older I don't
like your electric cars like the new
technology even in new Ferraris or new
Porsche I don't like the new technology
because they do everything so you can't
feel [ __ ] so my new my new [ __ ] is uh
Ferraris 2003 to 2006. really because
they're like naturally uh V8 aspirated
they're dope man you can feel the roads
they're loud as [ __ ] get like 10 miles a
gallon
um I don't like the electric [ __ ]
I like a car that has gas coming out of
it I even like a gas leak on a car well
dude there's nothing better I would say
make cologne out of gas oh you like a
car with no gas
yeah I want the gas to be out in the air
dude I love the smell of gas I know
people get pissed when they spill the
gas not men I love that [ __ ]
dude best thing I ever saw one time this
homeless dude went up to the gas tank
put gas on his hands and just rubbed it
around the edges of his freaking wiener
like that oh see I like that [ __ ]
give him 20 that'll wake you up I'd like
to do that if it wasn't frowned upon
dude if you ain't awake all day dog
after rubbing gas on the sides of your
wiener
then what are you even doing huh petrol
[ __ ] who is your leader Who's Your
Leader Chan what do you know about it
huh
if I had to choose being Ferrari and
Porsche or just my whatever I want no
foreign
yeah I think fires are cool you've seen
the new GT3 RS I think they both look
dope but for whatever reason the Ferrari
just seems to be like bigger for me
but dude if you're on trt you're gonna
look like little what's his name Yim
Jung young [ __ ] look like Wreck-It
Ralph in a Ferrari keep doing this trt
daddy I'm on the very like the lightest
smallest thing so try to maybe lose a
lot of my hair what's up get on
finasteride man it made me lose a lot
yeah too yeah I can I'm already losing
my hair so yeah here's what you don't
understand you don't understand the
difference between I'm already losing my
hair and oh damn more of my hair done no
but I'm also you don't realize you're on
the path to look like a Korean Mega mine
okay I just used to shave my head all
the time so I'm cool okay that's great
but for now start I'm worried about the
side effects the sexual side effects
dude Ed
tape a popsicle stick to your wiener
dude I don't want to do that you can't
but oh
the sexual stuff yeah you'll have you
will have
here oh okay so you're saying that you
don't want to have sex
yeah isn't that part of the benefit it
can be I I overused it in my day goes
like this ain't happening for about a
year damn wow I didn't give a [ __ ]
man my snail wouldn't wake up dog sweet
reprieve I didn't care look I've been
down that road Bob
won't wake up
yeah he's smoking I thought he's smoking
weed in the morning man without me
knowing I've been down that road where
my dick just ain't even doing with me no
more yep I thought he was dead
this was uh just coincidence we talked
crawfish and
dancing we made it to uh your mom's
stomping ground that Bubba spark Slidell
Louisiana gang baby you can't even stay
for y'all Everybody Eats that
everybody used to take good tail
oh
hilarious oh that's a good that [ __ ]
looks nice that looks good they got they
coming through baby are you a crawfish
fan I like crawfish man my brother does
a big boil every uh Year and I love
crawfish yeah it's good then twinkle
tradition it's just everywhere tradition
down there really everybody does it on
April but you guys you guys uh because I
used I used to work to this lady and she
would clean up the dishes and she like
suck would you say suck the heads eat
the Tails yeah it was discussions she
didn't have teeth big tits
body like an armadillo oh it'll eat the
enamel right off your [ __ ] teeth bro
so wait to get married to do it but uh I
think yeah I sucked the head man but I
never sucked it from the front like that
dude suck it from the back you sucked
that thing from the open part yeah the
back these sucking from the back oh it's
good man but yeah you get that thing out
the front but also what do you sucking
the brains out you just getting all the
juice that's been in there in the boil
you're getting that in your mouth if
you're getting a little uh are you
sucking the brains dog that's that's the
meat in the head if that thing has a
brain in it dude it ain't much
that's what you're eating though I've
never caught one of them [ __ ] at the
library dog
those things are on the side of the
ditch living in these little like tall
like things of uh bro right now I work
too hard to be sucking on the [ __ ]
brains of crawfish daddy that's true now
that's the other way to look at it is
that it's a poor man's snack like my
girl had she was like oh it's cow tongue
and cow intestine soup what's that [ __ ]
I work way too hard for you to eat this
yeah what are we doing you ain't
sleeping on the floors in Mexico anymore
oh yeah El pisos
um but yeah I think it's beautiful over
there Nick I always thought an interview
show uh like a crawfish boil in LA with
like a homeless encampment in the
background could be like Theo's hot ones
he's interviewing someone you're boiling
the fish you see the homeless like you
see La but you bring Louisiana Skid Row
uh not there's a million places you can
go you don't have to go
uh just because it's so you get the LA
feel with the Louisiana tradition and
he's interviewing someone
it's I used to go suck one I just know a
girl yeah
[Laughter]
or whatever and uh I went over to
crawfish bowl Stan verret came one time
it was in downtown L.A in a parking lot
people are eating them and in the
background homeless people were Milling
around and you know needling out or
whatever jousting jousting each other
bro I had a it was like a deep fried
crawfish but it was at an Asian place in
New York was out there doing PR for my
uh special and I ate the whiskers and
the eyeballs good they were crunchy
shrimp even when you deep fry shrimp you
eat everything damn that's that Korean
Koreans eat it all brother it don't
matter you know I've run across a lot of
Koreans recently I heard yeah John Park
yep famously Bobby Lee
um how do you guys eat squid
um
you want to [ __ ] with the head of the
squid all right I'm not squid uh eel oh
yeah we you know the face of the ear no
not the face damn no damn no face of the
eel that'd be a good scary movie huh
good Chinese movie
potentially the face but no face of the
year they're like I'm like facing a rock
facing the eel dude being gay yeah
facing the eel into black porn oh damn
boy that's crazy dude
that's crazy
hahaha
that might be the episode
Brendan might have come out with that
one man that's it that's a good one
that's it man
um me and you brother yeah man I got uh
uh what do we got
I got some shows coming up in Wichita
Omaha Denver oh bro you're doing
Paramount Theater in Denver that's my
that's my bucket list it is I know I've
made it really yeah as a kid I'd walk by
it has the big blue bear in front of it
I haven't seen it before yeah I'm
excited man we're gonna add some more
shows at the Paramount above where
they're gonna add them on a different
weekend
um my mom's gonna need tickets yeah yeah
you'll meet my mom bring her out dude
I'll bring her out yeah bring her out
yep she'll be could she do a few minutes
you think at the top oh yeah
that'd be good man
um and then ah where am I I'm in
Appleton Wisconsin Appleton September
8th through the 10th Ontario Ontario
Improv is September 15th to the 17th
that's one of my favorite clubs Ontario
Improv and then I end September in
Boston Boston's the 29th of September
through October 1st that's laugh Boston
and then San Jose Salt Lake City just
went on sale for October get you some
thickboy.com but uh Appleton and Ontario
you're up man
yeah and then I got some sad news I'm
gonna be taking a a step back from being
on uh King in the sting and uh
uh I just want to thank you guys for
um just being a part of my life and and
letting this show be a part of your life
and um
you know
um grateful to you Brandon mans
appreciate it
um
and yeah today was a lot of fun and the
best brother yeah it was the best today
was today was awesome funniest guy I
know thanks bro
appreciate that man
um [ __ ] we've been doing what four years
I don't know has it been that long
um
man yep
yeah I uh
just gotta handle some [ __ ] brother you
know yet there's a bigger thing for you
out there you know yeah I don't know I
don't know what it is exactly man I mean
yeah I mean I I
yeah I mean it's sad you know I feel sad
about it yeah you know
um
but it's it's still an exciting show and
there's great people here and
um
and
I think that that's important you know
that there's that it's a great show
still uh for people grateful of Chris
and Eric and everyone yeah and for
people to enjoy man and um
yeah I love you guys and uh yeah just
thank you so much there'll be some times
where I'll pop back in you know
um but just just I just don't want to
kind of leave that in the Lurch I feel
like I've left it there for a while and
I probably made it uncomfortable as a
listener maybe and just as a people
working here too you know not to be able
to you know be sure of me and
um so anyway thank you guys man I love
y'all and I love you bro I love you
brother you know that gang gang all
right guys Buzz Buzz for old times I
should have done this in the middle of
the show but for old times do we maybe
want to eat I'll eat a Hot Chip
I mean I'm down I don't want that okay
[Music]
how many times I gotta make this song
[Music]
it's the king and the sting in the way
let's go
Legendary Trio what you mean you know
it's the king and the sting and the wing